David Boder: [In English] Munich, September 21st, 1946. At the Baltic camp, populated by Lithuanians, Latvians and Estonians. The Interview is Ms. Bronė Skudaikienė, widow who claims that her husband was killed in Lithuania at the time of the Sowjet. She is 36 years old and has here 2 children.
David Boder: [In German] Wie alt sind die Kinder? Nochmal.
David Boder: [In English] One is 14 years old, und der andere six. Her German causes her difficulty. We will have interview probably part in German, part in Lithuanian.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Frau Skudaykina, sagen Sie mir mal, wo waren Sie, wenn die Sowjets gekommen sind nach Litauen?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Ich war in Litauen. In...
David Boder: Welche Stadt?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Žemaičių Kalvarija.
David Boder: Žemaičių Kalvarija? Wie weit ist das von Wilna?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Von Wilna? Von Wilna ist das 200.
David Boder: Ungefähr 200 km?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Ja.
David Boder: Und was haben Sie dort gemacht?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Ich war Molkereibuchhalter und mein Mann war Molkereileiter.
David Boder: Molkerei—Molkereibuchhalter und der Mann war Molkerei....
Bronė Skudaikienė: Molkereileiter
David Boder: Was hat Ihr Mann gelernt?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Ich .. alles, alles machen.
David Boder: Ja, ist er zur Schule gegangen, bevor...
Bronė Skudaikienė: Ja
David Boder: War er Agronom?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Nein, nicht Agronom. Alles Molkerei machen.
David Boder: Und was war das? Ein großes Gut? Wo war er in der Molkerei?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Alles arbeiten.
David Boder: [In English/German] Ja. Alright.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну, говорите по-литовски.
David Boder: [In German] So, sprechen Sie, erzählen Sie mir einfach, was hat passiert, wenn die Russen sind gekommen nach nach Litauen.
Bronė Skudaikienė: [In Lithuanian] Mano vyras dirbo, reiškia, pienininku, kaip visuomet, aš dirbau irgi pieninėj, kada bolševikai atėjo, mano vyras turėjo apykinkėj labai gerą pasitikėjimą terp ūkininkų, labai gerą pasitikėjimą terp ūkininkų, tas labai nepatiko bolševikams, mano bolševikas...kartu su bolševikais, mano vyras kartu su bolševikais nėjo išvien, tas labai nepatiko bolševikams, jie mano vyrą areštavo, areštavo keturiasdešimts pirmais metais sausio dvyliktą dieną. Uždarė Telšių kalėjime ir laikė ligi prasidėjo su vokiečiais karas. Karui prasidėsiant visus politiniu kaliniuss, jų tarpe ir mano vyrą, septyniasdešims tris vyrus žiauriausiu būdu nužudė Rainių miškelyje. Pirmiausia, buvo labai žiaurus jųjų suėmimas, sudėta į mašinas, ma...paleido motorus, kad negirdėtų jų riksmo, buvo surišti burnos, per burnas buvo pažaboti, rankos taip pat surištos, ir tuomet nuvežė į miškelį, tenai iškasė keturias duobes, juos žiauriausiu būdu nužudė. Būtent jie buvo labai žiauriai plikinami, paleistos elektrinės mašinos, paskui virinami kopūstai ir dedami jiems ant burnos...ir...buvo net išlupamos akys, nupjaustomi liežuviai, nupjaustomos ausys, ir tada jie buvo visi taip žiauriai nukankinti, sumušti, tiesiog suvirintos odos lūpuose, nuo rankų, nuo veidų, kūnas visas buvo kruvinas, ir surištomis rankomis, ir pažaboti jie buvo taip nužudyti, ir tuomet už...suversti visi į duobę ir užkasti. Ir tuomet jie visi bolševikai pabėgo iš Lietuvos. Praėjus keturioms dienoms tiktai tuomet reiškia rado partizanai tas duobes, buvo labai vis įtartina, ir atidarę duobes rado visus politkalinius. Tuomet juos visus iškasė, suguldė lauke, po tam susirinko visi ž...pažįstami, giminės, ir juos visus palaidojo labai iškilmingai, Telšių...Telšiuose tokių iškilmių ir tokio...tokios baisios eisenos turbūt labai retai kas yra matę.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну, а ес...теперь расскажите мне...
David Boder: [In German] Ah, jetzt erzählen Sie mir bitte, was hat Ihnen passiert und wie, wenn die Deutschen gekommen sind nach Litauen?
Bronė Skudaikienė: [In Lithuanian] Kada vokiečiai atėjo, taip pat irgi nebuvo labai, ba ūkininkams ir labai sunku, dėl to kad...dėl to, kad buvo labai didelės prievolės, rεikėjo ūkininkams statyti labai daug pienas, pienines, ke...mėsą, taip pat viskam, ir paskutiniu laiku, kada matė, kad vokiečiams labai blogai sekasi, tada labai gaudė vyrus, vežti į darbus į Vokietiją. Atvažiuodavo žmonės į turgų, tai apsupdavo turgų, paimdavo vietos policija, karuomenė, ir visus visus vyrus sugaudydavo sodydavo į mašinas ir veždavo į Vokietiją. Veždavo visus darbams. Taip kad atskirdavo vyrus nuo žmonų, tėvus nuo vaikų.
David Boder: [In Russian] Как вы сюда...
David Boder: [In German] Wie sind Sie nach München gekommen? Litauisch.
Bronė Skudaikienė: [In Lithuanian] Aš į Miuncheną atvažiavau keturiasdešimt penktais metais gegužės dvidešims trečią dieną.
David Boder: [In German] Haben Sie Verwandte in Amerika?
Bronė Skudaikienė: [In Lithuanian] Turiu...Mamos brolis ir vyro brolis yra...
David Boder: [In German] Haben Sie schon Afidavit bekommen?
Bronė Skudaikienė: [In Lithuanian] Ne
David Boder: Wollen Sie nach Amerika gehen?
Bronė Skudaikienė: [In Lithuanian] Jei galima, visuomet
David Boder: [In German] Haben Sie geschrieben dort? Haben sie die Adresse?
Bronė Skudaikienė: [In Lithuanian] Aš rašiau konsului paieškojimą, bet jokio atsakymo negavau.
David Boder: [In German] Haben Sie die Adresse?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Nein, in Konsulat ich geschicken. Sofia.
David Boder: Ach so, sie haben geschicken nach Sofia. Und was denken Sie, wie lange werden Sie hier sein?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Ich weiß nicht.
David Boder: Und was machen Ihre Kinder hier?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Gehen Schule.
David Boder: Gehen zur Schule?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Zur Schule.
David Boder: Litauische Schule?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Litauische Schule.
David Boder: Aha, und was machen Sie selbst?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Ich gehe in...Schneiderin machen.
David Boder: Sie sind Schneiderin, oder Sie lernen Schneiderin?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Nein, ich jetzt ausgelernt. Und jetzt arbeiten.
David Boder: Für wen?
Bronė Skudaikienė: Der Lagerschneider.
David Boder: Für die Lagerschneiderei. Danke sehr, Frau Skudaykina. Das ist sehr interessant. Es tut mir leid, dass ich nicht alles verstehe, aber hier ist es aufgeschrieben und wir werden es dort übersetzen.
Bronė Skudaikienė: Ja, danke.
David Boder: [In English] Munich, September the 21st of 1946. This concludes the short interview with B. Skudaykina, who insists on talking only Lithuanian and unfortunately very difficult for me to steer this conversation. It will be necessary that a competent Lithuanian anthropologist or psychologist really come over and really interview these people.
David Boder: This concluded Spool 9-143A and 9-143B. The last part, 9-143C, the interview with Father Kharchenko, is on a separate spool. This spool contains two interviews, one with Mr. Sevalkaitis or Suvalkaitis, and the other, 9-143B, is Bronė Skudaikienė. Chicago, October the 7th, 1950. Boder.